good morning belief nation today's
message is do it because you can't help
it over to you sir Paul McCartney what's
your inspiration to write I mean it must
be very difficult you to have any
material ambitions yeah but it's never
really been a material ambitions you
know I mean I remember we did used to
sit around when we were just starting
when we'd started to get our glimpse of
number ones and we did sit round and
kind of think okay now we'll write a
swimming pool yes
you know let's write a swimming pool now
let's write the garage and let's write a
car to go in it you know but that was
never really the big incentive I don't
think that's what made us write the
songs so now that in part of the
incentive isn't particularly there you
know because I've got the car and the
carrot in it but I don't really think it
was ever what what I was writing for or
else I probably wouldn't write now if I
didn't feel like that I sort of right
cuz I can't help it and cuz it's a bit
of a hobby still for me it's something
that if I'm in the mood I really like to
just go and do you know this is a
message I resonate really strong and
with because I will create things just
for the sake of creating even if I know
it's never going to get used and I think
of examples either creating my own or
creating for clients I'm working with I
look at Sage as an example you guys have
seen kind of the monthly hangouts how to
do with Stephen Kelly I'm always sending
them stuff that I know they're never
going to use even though I secretly hope
they will use right I wanted to rename
their conference from Sage Summit
there's something more powerful more
impactful I wanted to create some
marketing materials for them and new
campaigns that would touch people on an
emotional level and I'll sit there for
hours working on this stuff creating
entire campaigns and names for them and
send it off to them and it never gets
used and most people would think oh that
really sucks why would you why would you
keep going what would you keep doing
that
and it's not the end result that I'm
after it's not them actually using it
that I care about it would be awesome if
they actually took one of these things
that I've sent them and run with for me
it's much more I enjoy the challenge of
doing it and enjoy the creation process
I'm I'm driving home from taking my
parents to the airport and I'm thinking
about this and they just need to get
this idea out of my head and into
Photoshop and off to them or I won't be
able to sleep and I won't be able to
function I'll just be on my my mind all
the time and so I think too many
entrepreneurs or wannabe entrepreneurs
get started just thinking about what
that angle is gonna be right I'm making
this so that I can get this and you
don't enjoy what you're doing enough
right you do crappy work you do work
just because it's an opportunity you do
work is it's going to help you get rich
quick right that's why you take it on
and then you don't actually enjoy the
work if you look at entrepreneurs all
the successful ones they enjoy the
process yes they may have enjoyed the
result but they enjoy the process too I
enjoy making videos for you guys I enjoy
jumping in the comments with you I enjoy
running Toronto and salsa right I enjoy
the stuff that I'm doing and and you
should enjoy the creation process and
creep because you just can't help doing
it you would do it even if you weren't
getting paid to do it because you love
it so much so the question that if you
guys today is I want to know what you
just can't help but do that you would do
even if you weren't getting paid for it
leaving the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events pressing
nespresso give me go